[Music]
pokeymon has always been a series about
going on an adventure discovering new
locations catching and raising pokemon
and becoming the best there ever was
this has held true for every generation
of games the latest entry is Pokemon Sun
and Moon present you with a detailed and
beautiful tropical setting to explore
brand new challenges to face and plenty
of new Pokemon - catch and care for it's
a fun charming little adventure but as
much as I was enjoying my time with it
something felt missing its difficulty
ever since X&Y Pokemon has become
ridiculously easy perhaps from a desire
for accessibility for new players and
while there's still plenty of things to
love about these games the lack of
difficulty not only is off-putting for
someone looking for more of a challenge
but it also diminishes the adventurous
spirit that Pokemon is all about one of
the things that made X&Y so darn easy
was the XP share which had been changed
to apply to the whole party so that
everyone gets some experience from the
battle the result was that I never
needed to grind and my Pokemon were over
leveled for pretty much every situation
Sun and Moon has actually attempted to
course-correct this by changing how much
XP is gained based on the difference
between the levels of you and your
opponent but it doesn't feel fully there
yet
I still rarely enter a battle worried
about the level of my Pokemon or if I
was prepared for the fight aside from
the lack of mental challenge this
created an effect where I suddenly had
far less investment in my pokemons
spending time in the tall grass grinding
with a specific Pokemon so that it
learns that one move I need helped form
an attachment with it but that no longer
happens when I never need to spend any
time grinding anymore and because my
whole party is getting XP from battles
there was no reason to switch them
around as often meaning I have a
situation where I only really use two or
three members of my party and the rest
are faceless pokemons that I have no
attachment to and can be swapped out
without a second thought these games
have really liked to put an emphasis on
the friendships between you and your
pokemons but they significantly reduce
the need to interact with them directly
another dynamic that has changed is your
rival a Pokemon staple you are always
given an opposing character who
counter pick whichever started Pokemon
you pick so if you pick Charmander and
pokemons read your rival will pick
squirtle those moments where your rival
would show up out of nowhere felt tense
because they always had the advantage
and you've had a stake and not wanting
to lose to them because they were such a
real jerk to you but ever since
generation 3 your rival has been your
character's friend with a healthy
competition towards each other this
removes a lot of attention towards them
and gives me much less of a reason to
care when they want to fight this
reaches its peak in Sun and Moon where
your rival actually picks the weaker
pokemons so battles against them are a
total breeze I never felt any stress
when he randomly showed up and his
attitude towards everything is so
carefree that referring to him as a
rival it doesn't even make sense anymore
well the pokemons themselves have always
been the main focus I think something
often overlooked in these games are the
environments themselves and the
interesting challenges they can present
because Pokemon centers were always
located only in towns and cities there
was a real sense of danger and risk that
came from leaving each town and
exploring the many routes forests and
caves throughout the world unaware of
how long it would be until the next time
you could heal and the newer games are
so many Pokemon Center is littered about
and NPCs who will just straight-up heal
you to the point where I never felt
concerned about being low on health as I
was exploring a route in Sun and Moon
just when I thought to myself I should
head back to town and heal before moving
on the NPC next to me graciously offered
to heal my Pokemon whenever I wanted
instead of that original Pokemon feeling
of being a kid going on a dangerous but
rewarding adventure where I have to
prove myself I'm instead on an easy
journey where nothing could go wrong
thanks to the many adults and safety
nets nearby and this feeling is cemented
with Sun and moons removal of the
dungeon like caves the caves and the
older games always felt like huge
milestones in your journey you had to
conquer there are multi-level labyrinths
that were easy to get lost in and would
feature puzzles such as blocks you had
to push out of the way or through holes
so they could drop to a different floor
and ice puzzles that you needed to find
the correct path through the caves
always felt like the areas where the
game wasn't afraid to beat on the player
a bit like the infamous Rock Tunnel from
red and blue where you had to stumble
through blind unless your Pokemon knew
flash with each cave I'd find myself
preparing by getting my pokemon healed
up
pokeballs potions and good old escape
ropes before diving in exploring every
nook and cranny led to items and even
rare Pokemon and when you finally found
the exit you were rewarded with a huge
sense of relief and satisfaction as you
saw the next town and its Pokemon Center
compare this to Sun and Moon where the
first cave I came across was a simple
single leveled environment with barely
any side paths and no puzzles to speak
of and before I knew it I had already
found the exit I'm surprised the game
still has the escape rope as an item
because the player is never in a
situation that demands a quick getaway
perhaps the most insulting instance is
when I had to travel to the top of a
volcano for the next trial so I go to
the base of the mountain go through some
grass fight a single trainer and then I
come across the cave entrance but rather
than leading to a cave proper it
instantly teleports me to the top where
a person congratulate Smee on making it
this high and then heals my Pokemon in
an interaction that I'm pretty sure is
supposed to be genuine but came off as
incredibly pandering this was a prime
opportunity to make me work for my trial
with a memorable trek up this volcano
but instead it skips all that and
rewards me like I accomplished some huge
feat that I never actually felt like I
did at another example of this kind of
more guided experience in the series is
the recent treatment of the mascot
legendary Pokemon which are the ones on
the boxes with each generation these
legend areas have become more important
to the game's overall narrative
which means you're not only guaranteed
to come across them but are required to
catch them for the story to move forward
ever since black and white they have
jacked up the catch rate of the mascot
legendaries making them ridiculously
easy to catch not that it matters if you
do fail because you were given as many
chances as it takes until you catch them
compare that to Pokemon silverware if
I've wanted to catch lugia I needed to
make my way to the world through Islands
traverse a complex cave to find them and
then actually catch the darn thing which
could take dozens of attempts I remember
spending what felt like hours reloading
my save whenever I ran out of pokeballs
are accidentally knocked them out which
may sound terrible but the satisfaction
of hearing that click when I finally
caught them was so rewarding and that
feeling just isn't possible when there
are no stakes to it the reason games
like Sun and Moon still have Legendary's
and rare Pokemon that demand players
devote time and energy to finding them
the
are all post credit activities and it's
in some of these side activities where
pokemons retained some of its challenge
things like the Battle Royale which
present a 4-way match up where you need
to think more carefully about what moves
you use and who to attack and those who
choose to enter the realm of battles
with real players will discover lots of
hidden depth that the battle system
still has to offer and I think Sun and
Moon is not quite the cakewalk that xny
was the totem Pokemon battles for
example can be tricky with beefed up
stats and pokemons allies that show up
but I still maintain the mainline
experience that Pokemon presents is far
too easy and lessens the overall
memorability of your pokemons journey
and at least to me that's kind of the
whole point of Pokemon I don't need
these games to be some hardcore brutal
experience but I expected a rewarding
journey that really makes me connect
with my Pokemon and the world around me
but there needs to be more weight and
challenge for that to happen otherwise
victory road doesn't really feel like
much of a victory anymore
[Music]